hey y'all this is jake hoot and i'm here
at the kelly clarkson show and i'm
building my voice dream team
all right so the rules are i get to pick
five people
from former coaches mentors and
contestants
the one rule that they told me i have to
stick to is i can't pick kelly so let's
do it
so for the first part of my roster i'm
going to pick a coach and i'm going to
go with the la cowboy
blake shelton i love blake i've sang his
music for a lot of years and honestly
a lot of people may not know that when i
came on the show i initially wanted him
to turn
but he didn't and kelly ended up turning
and
we ended up winning the show together
and kelly's just an incredible person
but
i would if i can't pick kelly i would
definitely go with blake shell
so for roster spot number two it has to
be a mega mentor and i would probably go
with james taylor
i was so bummed that he was the mega
mentor of the season
after i was on it but i had taylor swift
on mine so it made up for it but i love
james taylor's music i mean mom
let us listen to him growing up and
sweet baby james and
just so many classic hits that he had
with that that smooth voice and that
incredible guitar playing
so i'm definitely having to go with
james taylor
[Music]
so roster spot number three has to be
a former voice winner and i know it's a
little
a little cliche but i'm probably gonna
have to go with my good buddy todd
tillman from season 18 he and i become
great friends and i can remember hearing
him for the first time and hearing that
smokey smooth voice that he had
and plus i mean you know he's a pastor
and everything else and i'm a missionary
kid so obviously
we have that chemistry but honestly he's
one of the sweetest people you'll ever
meet
nobody more deserving of winning the
show so i'm gonna go with mr todd
tillman
[Music]
so spot number cuatro on
my roster it has to be a fellow boys
contestant from my season which was
season 17. i'm going
gonna go with mr ricky badman duran
um he and i struck up a friendship uh
early on in the show
and i had no idea how great of a guitar
player he was and towards the end we did
this like little
you know i don't know video thing or
whatever and he started playing guitar
and i said you're a bad man and ever
since then it stuck as bad man duran and
not long ago i released
a my version of la bamba and i had ricky
actually come sing on it and play guitar
on it
so if anybody is going to be on the team
it's got to be ricky
[Music]
the last spot on my roster the dream
team is somebody who i think could have
should or could have however you want to
say one at all and i'm gonna go with the
swann brothers
i remember the season that they were on
i was living in the dominican republic
with my family and i remember hearing
their music
on you on youtube watching it and going
oh my gosh these dudes are so good i
have since interviewed them once on like
a little show that i had done
but you know just the music that they
continue to put out and just those
harmonies that they've got and their
personalities
i easily think they could have won it
all great guys even better musicians i'm
gonna go with the swan brothers as my
last spot on the roster
all right y'all i'm about to sign off
that was my dream team
and you know let me know who you'd pick
on your dream team i'm hoping that i'm
making the list but if i'm not it's okay
i forgive you
but in the meantime y'all be sure to
tune in march 31st
to watch me and kelly sing our single
together i would have loved you on the
kelly clarkson show
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever